[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous je m'appelle sonia que je
suis très impressionné là tout de suite
je suis venu vous parler de quelque
chose de très évident mais qui me tient
à coeur et que j'ai envie de rappeler il
vous est peut-être déjà arrivés comme
moi un moment dans une soirée dans une
conversation vous dit tout est lié et
bien moi cette petite pensée me revient
de plus en plus souvent et surtout
depuis qu'il est arrivé un truc de fou
c'était il ya quelques années au large
le saint paul 1 pleine mer dans le grand
bleu et j'ai eu la chance de pouvoir
nager avec une baleine et son baleineau
dans le grand bleu vous riez limite pas
plus loin que les palmes et là tout d'un
coup il ya cette petite silhouette qui
peut titre qui se découpe comme ça dans
le bleu et est ce que j'ai vécu là à ce
moment c'était c'était immense j'étais
dans l'environnement naturel d'une
créature géante et pourtant si paisible
si curieuse j'ai ressenti absolument
plus aucune peur et à ce moment là je me
suis dit tout est lié pas seulement moi
et la baleine mais tout on est tous liés
nook ou existants nous partageons une
même planète
avec tant d'espèces qui sont
merveilleuses plus périlleuses les unes
que les autres
on peut s'émerveiller de avatar ou de
starwars com
mais mais toi tu es là il y en a qui
vont chercher des pokémon un peu partout
mais il suffit de regarder dans les
rayons il suffit de regarder dans les
jardins dans la nature il ya tout sur
place si vous demandez à james cameron
le réalisateur d'avatar ou est-ce qu'il
a puisé son inspiration il va pas
chercher pas le chercher bien loin c'est
un grand explorateur des fonds marins et
il a tout trouvé sur la planète
pas besoin d'aller sur pandora il ya
et ce lien comme ça on peut le recréer
on peut le créneau aussi c'est une force
il ya beaucoup d'espèces comme je vous
ai dis en tant qu'espèce humaine on est
assez peu de choses par rapport à la
diversité du monde animal et végétal et
pourtant on a une influence majeure est
souvent néfaste et je me demande souvent
comment est ce qui se peut qu'une espèce
comme la nôtre qui est censé être
intelligente arrive à détruire à petit
feu mais tout ce qui nous relient les
uns aux autres est ce que j'aimerais
vous demander dans un premier temps
c'est de vous laisser émerveiller
justement partout de ces choisi de
retrouver du lien avec la nature avec la
chine
et puis aussi avec les gens les humains
je pense que ce lien-là perdu en cours
de route on l'a oublié on les laissait
de côté on s'est mis à considérer la
nature les animaux repus même les
humains comme des ressources et de clous
pour transformer cela mais il faut
recréer du lien avec la nature je veux
pas vous demander d'aller en rentrant
chez vous parlez à vos plantes même si
j'en connais avait dans la salle qui
n'hésiteraient pas mais prenez un
instant et je vous le faites déjà
certainement pour pour contempler et
contempler avec tous vos sens tout ce
qui vous entoure et c'est valable comme
je le disais pour la nature pour les
animaux et pour les humains c'est déjà
en arriver à recréer du lien au sein de
notre espèce humaine
je pense que ça changerait pas mal de
choses et il ya du boulot parce que les
7,43 milliards d'êtres humains sur terre
c'est dire que le 43 milliards cet arrêt
moi je lui ça me fait s'il essaie 7,43
milliards d'êtres humains ils sont tous
y est tous et une amie qui m'a parlé
d'un petit exercice à faire c'est de
dire merci
prenez un objet chez vous et vous
essayez de dire merci à toutes les
personnes qui ont fait que cet objet
existe et est entre votre possession
avec ce seul fils d'idée si vous
remontez remontée remontée remontée
pourrait faire le tour du monde
ça aussi c'est harry et pour créer du
lien il suffit parfois que d'une seule
personne
je pourrais vous incitez plein gandhi
pierre rabhi tous les colibris qui
existe à travers le monde et il ya un
exemple qui me revient plus précisément
en tête c'est celui de père johnson
c'est une simple citoyenne américaine
qui s'est mis à changer son mode de vie
qu décidé de partager en écrivant un
livre son expérience son expérience et
sur le zéro déchet au fil des abs émises
à réduire pièce par pièce tous les
déchets qu'elle pouvait produire chez
elle et elle arrivait au bout d'un
arrivé à un point où en un an
la totalité de ces déchets ménagers camp
nou on accule plein et plein de poubelle
elle ces déchets ménagers tiennent dans
un tout petit bocal
là encore c'est fou et et j'ai lu ce
bouquin là au même moment où je
travaillais avec une association sur une
action autour de la gestion des déchets
dans cette association j'ai rencontré un
des membres qui m'a parlé d'une autre
association qui s'intéressait j'ai
tellement appris ce qu'était
développement durable j'ai participé à
un festival sur les alternatives et j'ai
rencontré une jeune dame qui venait tout
juste d'ouvrir la première boutique de
vrac à la réunion et ben voilà toutes
les clés pour arriver aujourd'hui au
zéro déchet ou les
moi j'en suis pas encore arrivé là mais
mais voilà ce lien qui a été créée par
cette simple mère de famille aux
etats-unis qui a décidé juste de
témoigner il est arrivé jusqu'à voir en
passant par une infinie quantité de
personnes tout au long du parcours les
gens à la télé les gens de l'association
de l'autre association
cette dame qui a ouvert sa boutique et
tout est lié et ça moi ça me trouble et
il a suffi que d'une seule personne et à
ce moment-là je me dis wow c'est fort et
ça me donne envie surtout et se rendre
compte des liens qui existent à travers
le monde entre entre nous entre les gens
c'est fort et est l'étape d'après cette
créer du lien à son tour moi je pense
avoir trouvé ma manière je vais vous
raconter une petite histoire quand
j'étais gamine
à la question qu'est ce que tu fais ce
que tu veux faire quand tu feras grande
j'ai changé 1150 fois david au moins
quand j'ai vu macgyver à la télé je
voudrais être maquilleuse quand je
lisais jules verne je voulais explorer
le monde
quand j'ai vu l'urgence je voulais être
urgentistes bien évidemment et comme
j'ai vu superman je voulais être loïs
lane pourrait peser superman
et aujourd'hui j'ai toujours du mal à me
demander ce que je veux faire alors je
suis devenu journaliste comme luis lane
mais je suis aussi bricoleuse je fais de
la musique je suis engagé dans plein
d'associations je fais vraiment plein de
choses j'essaye tout j'ai souvent pensé
que c'était un défaut lorsqu'on finit
pas toujours ce qu'on commence quand on
part dans tous les sens mais je pense
aujourd'hui avoir réussi à en faire une
force
quand j'étais gamine aussi je regardais
le téléthon et je me disais c'est chaque
personne en france donne un france après
60 millions de francs à l'époque c'était
énorme et cette idée là avec cette idée
là je me disais voilà c'est le concept
ultime pour résoudre plein de problèmes
et à ma jamais quitté style est là et
aujourd'hui est devenu réalité avec ce
qu'on appelle le développement
participatif jeudi développement parce
que c'est bien plus que du financement
pour moi c'est des échanges et du coup
j'ai vu l'éclosion de ces plateformes
sur internet
et là j'ai vu oui c'est ça que je veux
faire et j'ai créé une plateforme pour
la réunion pour commencer à tisser des
liens autour de moi le développement
participatif pour vous expliquer c'est
simple c'est les petits ruisseaux font
les grandes rivières ou des grande
ravine puisqu'on est à la réunion permet
un porteur de projet de présenter son
idée et demandé le soutien de la foule
du grand public
chacun peut donner un petit peu et un
petit peu plus un petit peu ça fait un
bout et du coup avec avec cette plate
forme j'ai réussi à créer quelque chose
en utilisant monde idéal de gavin et en
retrouvant aussi le moyen de faire de ce
côté disperser une force puisque avec
cette plateforme
je peux travailler avec des artistes des
peintres des sculpteurs tout je peux
travailler avec des associations avec
des entrepreneurs avec des gens qui
oeuvrent pour le développement durable
pour la culture
et voilà j'ai trouvé mon truc juste en
essayant de créer du lien autour et il
ya des moments difficiles bien sûr comme
dans tout bon départ d'entreprise il ya
des
qui sont vraiment décourageant mais
pardonnez moi l'expression mais je kiffe
ce que je fais j'adore créer du lien je
contribue à mon tout petit niveau à
lancer comme ça des bouteilles à la mer
qu'ils ont entreprises part peut-être
d'autres choses et c'est fort c'est
aussi intense que ma rencontre avec la
balade main quand on crée du lien
on a le sentiment que tout est là et que
tout est possible quand on crée du lien
n'est invincible
c'est de l'énergie dame et ses virages
là par exemple je suis en train de vous
contaminer et j'espère que demain
eh ben c'est bien ils vont continuer à
se propager à grandir rayonner partout à
la réunion déjà ce serait bien et puis
ensuite dans l'océan indien qui partout
dans le monde
ça va pas venir de moi ça va venir de
tout le monde de chacun d'entre vous
aussi et il suffit juste de se rappeler
que tout est lié la baleine
macgyver les pokémon les insectes bea
johnson
wendy james cameron et moi 7 milliards
7,43 milliards d'êtres humains mois et
puis vous tous et j'aimerais terminer
brillamment en reprenant un petit peu
une idée du mahatma gandhi qui est soyez
le changement et moi j'ajouterais créer
les liens que vous souhaitez voir
prospérer dans ce monde
[Applaudissements]